just quick show of hands how many people
have seen black mirror on Netflix okay
that's a good number it's at least most
people I think which is good because
otherwise it talked might fall a little
flag but it's okay if you haven't I do
highly recommend you do watch it it's a
great show I just don't want it right
before you go to sleep it's a little
creepy what it does is it examines
technology kind of taken to the next
step or to the extreme and and when it
does that it shows kind of the negative
impacts that that can have but at its
core what it's really about is the
innate flaws in humanity and how
technology can kind of exacerbate that
if we're not careful and it uses our
screens right these things that we have
in front of us are phones that when
they're off they provide this very dark
image of ourselves right there this
black mirror and and it uses those
screens and that technology again to
shine a light and comment on some of our
innate human and human flaws that we
need to be careful about as we go
through technology so for those who may
not have seen that I do want to run
through a couple of examples but I swear
I'll tie it back into DevOps so first in
nosedive we see the idea of ranking each
other in social media kind of lead to
the loss of our humanity right we see
this chasing a number in a ranking
ranking every interaction with each
other as kind of not aligning us to the
values that actually make for a good
human being and and not you know that
don't make for a good person those are
not the same things that make for a
great social media presence
Haiden in the nation takes the problem
with the loss of bees and says oh well
we could fix it with autonomous bee
drones right why not that's great and so
automation for automation sake you can
kind of be not a great thing it could be
weaponized easily even if we have kind
of audacious braggadocious thought
process that add this you know no one
who can ever hack this system and it
also shows us people loving to vilify
others from behind their computer
screens and the anonymity that that
provides
and then lastly there's a lot of other
episodes that show you know when we
institutionalize part of society is bad
that can have some serious negative
consequences so this is white bear men
against fire white Christmas these all
show that when we decides a society that
one thing is bad and another thing is
good we can really exacerbate that with
technology in a way that we don't intend
so these kind of seem like horror
stories but they also seem to be just a
minute away from where we are right now
and so in thinking about that you know I
was thinking about you this is really
about applying technology in the right
way and I think that's what we as DevOps
practitioners try to do every day and so
I said what about our world what about
DevOps and I said you know season four
just came out a month or two ago on
Netflix and I said well what if they
were the Netflix writers decided to make
season five about DevOps what would that
look at look like and so I've got six
episodes of season five to talk about
and the interesting thing is episodes
one through three have actually already
been released there are things that have
happened already and so we're gonna talk
about that the first is the Equifax
breach pretty much everyone in the room
knows about that if you don't it was a
hundred and forty six million people
whose social security number and date of
birth were leaked that includes myself
my wife and three of my four children
the fourth she was safe only because she
wasn't born and didn't have a social
security number when the breach happened
so she's cool but the rest of us we were
part of this breach and how did it
happen well Equifax had a piece of open
source software Apache struts a lot of
us use patchy products or I mean assault
open source libraries and there was a
major vulnerability released and it was
patched by Apache within about three
days of it being released but Equifax
left this in their production
environment for over a year and people
had you know full rein the hackers that
perpetrated this had full rein over
their environment for over a year and
then once the light was shined on them
crabs on security
actually then found that their
argentinian employee site at admin admin
as a login so so again once once that
lights kind of shine on you there's
there's lots of places that you can
break down and some of us you know we
can we can look at Equifax and say well
that's not us you know we have a plan in
place but meltdown inspector takes that
plan off the table right and there's
gonna be a talk tomorrow
by Barbara who I haven't met but she's
here somewhere she's talking tomorrow
about meltdown inspector in detail and
she was supposed to we were supposed to
go to the other orders so I was gonna
have all that but just if you don't know
what that was a quick summary basically
you know a processor processors got so
fast that we decided instead of waiting
to figure out if a or B is gonna be true
we'll just run trains down both tracks
and then whichever one that ends up
being true we take and we throw away the
other trains the problem with this beam
it allowed other applications running on
the same processor as us to hijack that
second train that wasn't going to be
used and actually read the memory of our
applications which is really bad thing
that's the one thing we don't think
about we think about data arrests and we
think about data and transit but we
don't think about the actual memory of
our applications most of us that program
in a modern programming language and so
that's that's that's a really bad thing
and this xkcd I think summarizes it
really well it's probably impossible to
read but my favorite part of it says do
we just suck at computers and she says
yep especially shared ones and then the
third episode is night capital so if you
don't know about night capital this is
talked about in a lot of DevOps circles
night capital lost four hundred and
forty million dollars in a day and in a
day actually I mean in 45 minutes that's
two times their quarterly revenue at the
time and how did this or ten million
dollars a minute and so how did this
happen well when they looked at what
happened what happened was there was a
manual deploy to production of new
trading software and the person that
manually deployed that software put it
on seven production servers prom is they
have eight production server
and so with at first when when trading
open to that day everyone knew something
was wrong just because the volume of
trades the knight was doing but they
didn't have a kill switch they couldn't
kill it and so as they're scrambling to
figure out what's going on they actually
said well we just updated let's roll
back so you roll back the update so that
only the broken code was in production
none of the working code and actually
made it worse
so yeah it's not great so again those
are three episodes that have happened
already and and do show us you know what
can go wrong when we when we are
arrogant about our pipelines but there's
four other episodes I want to talk about
that I think could be we could just be a
minute away from if we're not careful
episode 4 I call the illusion of safety
so we open on a playground dad as
watching his kids play as I mentioned I
have four so I'm familiar with this he's
watching them he's laughs as they're
they're running around suddenly his
phone rings he looks at the phone and he
sees who it is and he puts it right back
down in his pocket but as soon as it
touches his pocket it starts ringing
again and as he picks up the phone
everything around him fades to black we
have we see that he's not in the park at
all he's in the office on Sunday he's
trying to figure out what parts of their
infrastructure are impacted by a huge
security breach a security issue that
was discovered on Friday and he doesn't
know what's impacted and what's not and
his boss is calling him trying to figure
out hey are we protected from this thing
I'm I'm hearing about in the news
because his boss doesn't want a phone
call from Congress to come testify why
they left us this vulnerable thing in
their system for so long episode 5 I
call Sisyphean development which was a
dangerous word to put into presentation
because I had to say it but that's ok so
in this one you know the fixes and the
features that a customer wants they're
done they've been coded they've been
done for weeks but we keep going back
over and over trying to integrate them
in meeting after meeting after meeting
trying to figure out what's wrong why it
doesn't integrate why this other code
the code that this customer needs and
Molly wakes up every morning here's our
alarm and hits it knowing that you know
she just kind of grunts disapprovingly
because she knows it's gonna be another
groundhog day of scrum meetings that
really don't solve the the core problem
of being able to integrate this code in
the last episode I call episode 6
superhero or tax collector so in this
episode
Ned is awake before his alarm the need
for his super powers awakened him from
even the deepest slumber he can he puts
on his cape he puts on the rest of his
suit he goes into work at work everyone
knows that he's a superhero and he knows
it he's got a tool for every problem in
every problem that comes up you know Ned
knows what to put onto that and fix it
but in reality that's not how his
colleagues see him they see him as a tax
collector they see him as every time
there's a new problem there's some tool
that we have to go by spend money to
integrate and and take actually longer
in the end to deliver on software so
they don't see him as a superhero they
seem as a tax collector
but it's not too late I do believe that
it doesn't have to be this way and that
actually we are all uniquely positioned
to make it not be this way as DevOps
professionals right we've been given
this gift to see these kinds of problems
we've seen other people have them and
fall on their face we'vewe've we know
that innately these things can happen
but that gives us the chance to make a
better future for us for our development
colleagues and for our customers and so
there's some solutions to these problems
that I want to talk about next right I
think all of these things boil down to
avoiding the DevOps tax we don't want to
be seen as just a cost center to the
business we want to be seen as a
strategic advantage to the business and
DevOps when it was first coined was seen
as exactly that but in practice it isn't
always that way and so and so how do we
make it that way well first of all I
think we have to take responsibility for
I think that's the most critical thing
we are the DevOps professionals in this
room that's why we're here that's why we
came to this conference we have to be
the change that we seek in our
organization
to drive this home and so again that
sounds really great but the next
question I would have if I were you is
Brendan what can I do today
so I want to dive into a couple of
things that we can go back and do today
well not today not tomorrow I would have
said Friday but anyway Monday what can
you do Monday take the weekend but then
Monday what can you do to to improve how
we deliver software and the first one
I'm going to talk about is not
interfacing with things like security
security should not be at the end of the
pipeline it shouldn't be something we
interface with it should be integrated
an entire pipeline we also don't want to
let our organizations think of DevOps as
just automated bills right that is not
DevOps and we'll and we'll talk about
why DevOps should enable development
teams to move as fast as possible from
getting ideas all the way from the
business concept into production
environments and in order to do that
well we've heard a couple talks about it
today I think we'll hear more but we
have to orchestrate monitoring in the
beginning and and into all of our
software pipelines so first one was
security my wife told me I could not
present at a tech conference and not
have a Star Wars reference so I got Star
Wars and a meme in one it's a
two-for-one deal what does this mean I
think it means we need to shift left
what we're doing with security right
security cannot be at the end of what
we're doing at an afterthought it has to
be every commit every time in order to
do that it has to be automated and when
we do that it becomes not a burn on
teams today it's a burden people say oh
you know yeah we got to do security
before the end of the release and we're
gonna run run the security tests and
it's gonna come back with 150 things and
then we're gonna have this horrible
choice of well do we accept the risk of
these 150 possible security issues some
of them are probably probably false
positives maybe I don't care about them
or do I delay the release to the
customer and so if we're if we're not
bringing security into the pipeline in
the beginning and shifting it to the
left
in our pipelines we're making it a
burden on our teams and high-performing
teams get this and yes I'm from gate lab
and yes I put a get joke in it which
everyone that works at get lab told me
not to keep in but I kept it in so now
you know how hard I am so but but it's
true there was a survey done and we've
got some more data on the next slide
that shows that high-performing teams
spend 50 percent less time remediating
security issues than their lower
performing counterparts and along with
that they have almost 30 percent more
automated tests and so if we want to
build high-performing teams which i
think is what we all want to do in this
in this industry we have to embrace this
and why is it so important well the same
survey and this graph may be hard to
read it's been iterated on a number of
times but I'll tell you what it says
it's okay in a survey of security
professionals that had experienced a
penetration attack to their environment
they were asked how was the attack
performed and the top two bars there the
top is software vulnerability and the
second bar is a web vulnerability
cross-site scripting sequel injection
that kind of stuff so those are the top
two ways actual attacks in the wild are
being performed and things that we think
about or maybe make the news a little
bit more like denial service denial
services see I can't even read it denial
of service is fourth and phishing attack
is actually the second to last and then
all others is the last bar so those are
the attacks that get a lot of attention
because I think they kind of speak to
you know a gloomy er world view of what
an attacker does but how they're really
carried out is through sulfur
vulnerabilities and and so based on that
what should have Equifax look like right
what what why was it possible for them
to have this issue in production for
almost a year well if we truly automate
the entire software development
lifecycle and shift security left it's
so much simpler it's not a hard problem
to solve them so instead of a manual
alert to someone
which someone at Equifax did get and did
not tell the right people about instead
of a manual Alert about some CVE that
came out or having to read through every
CBE myself your your software pipeline
should know what libraries and open
source libraries you're using and based
on that it should also then look at what
vulnerabilities come out and if it knows
that you use Apache struts 1.2.5
and it sees a vulnerability come out and
says okay there's now one point two
point six it should automatically create
a merge request for that put it into
testing if we test if we care and enough
about our tests then it should be able
to test and put that into prod and
instead of waking up to an email of
seventeen CV that came out over the
weekend if we could all go to we could
all go to happy hour tonight go to bed
some major Apache thing gets released
over overnight it was let's say it was
it was a white hat hacker that found it
so the patch is immediate to them
announcing the vulnerability instead of
waking up to an email about the
vulnerability and our boss is calling us
because they saw on CNN this morning
this huge vulnerability that exists we
wake up to an email that says oh your
production systems already patched right
that's what it should be that's what it
should look like so that's security next
automated builds are not CI CD and I
think my fellow speakers have kind of
stressed this and trustless as well but
I also translated into a number of
languages here to make it very clear so
the this see part of continuous
integration and continuous delivery is
often lost what's the C stand where
continuous right that means we have to
integrate code early and often in the
process and to do that again we have to
care about our tests and care about test
passing it's not okay to have flaky
tests because then the human being or
our human minds will just write off all
the tests we've written and and not care
about them and then the D in in C D you
know some people say it's delivery some
people say it's deployment I think it's
both I think it's critical that we care
about delivery and have automated
packaging and automate a release process
these if we don't have that we're not
gonna be able to release fast enough we
cannot have manual steps in that process
and I think again to do continuous
deployment automated deployment is
obviously required and we and we saw an
example of that in the last talk there's
lots of different ways to do that but I
think it's a requirement because in
order to move at the speed of our
developers and the speed the developers
are able to deliver code we have to be
able to deploy into production
automatically and then last is data is
the new testing so I also have to get a
Mean Girls reference in there so now you
you all fully met me and so I took I
took the the old adage what is what is
measured can be improved and I said no
no what is monitored can be improved
right
the SDLC right we say oclc a lot it's a
life cycle again
don't lose that life cycle part of it it
does not have an end and and because of
that monitoring has to be part of the
plan from the beginning and if it's not
we've already lost right when monitoring
is part of the plan and we have
automated deploy and continuous
deployment now we can easily ship canary
into production see how something works
iterating on it on it much faster see
how it operates in an actual production
environment with actual customers using
our code and that really allows us to
ship what we want the way we want a ship
which is ship the minimally viable
change every time so that we can we can
really accelerate delivery into
production so you know again I'm acutely
aware because this is the first startup
I've worked for a gitlab that sometimes
when I get lab person or someone from a
startup gets on stage someone might say
yeah that's great Brendan that's great
for startups but but not in my industry
and around here I think that's
especially true right the federal
government we all think oh they don't
move fast enough so not in my industry
but I think that's that's dangerous and
I think time has shown us how dangerous
that can be
right let's think about very traditional
industries that that probably felt that
way oh we're not right for disruption
right transportation transportation very
old industry
but was hugely disrupted by Tesla
entering the market and even more so by
ride sharing platforms entering the
market something even more basic like
healthcare has been incredibly disrupted
by Amazon deciding to enter that market
and what CVS has done even more basic
than healthcare as groceries right basic
human need and again Amazon hugely
disrupted that market by buying Whole
Foods and then just stuff right Internet
of Things means that everything is right
for disruptions so just things and stuff
and and thus your industry despite what
anyone tells you and I just want to look
at Amazon again for a second so this to
prove the point are the major health
care providers in this country with
their stock prices rebased to the time
that Amazon announced they were entering
the market with healthcare and so you
can see the immediate impact that them
just announcing it they don't even have
anything together yet but Amazon
announcing their entry and what that did
to shareholder value eight value or for
those health care companies and so again
your industry is right for this no
matter what what you say and if you say
yeah Brendon I get it
I get it but my boss doesn't get it you
know I think again it's important to
remember that we are the DevOps
professionals and we need to make that
our problem right we need to be able to
explain better to our leadership why
this is a problem and why they need to
care about it for the business and and
that again take the responsibility on
ourselves and then just kind of lastly I
think it's critical to know that
everyone can contribute I think it's
critical to acknowledge that we need to
not build silos between different
departments right that's the original
idea behind putting the two words
development and operations together into
DevOps and it's something that really
hasn't been fully realized yet but we
have the ability to realize that if we
if we build bridges instead of silos and
and that will allow us to put the
customer value first and allow us not to
let perfect get in the way of good or
perfect get in the way of shipped right
and oh one other thing I had to mention
because I said I would mention it on
Twitter which is someone came up with a
bunch of caveman black mirror episodes
which I loved so that's kind of the
opposite thing and my favorite is what a
fire but too much so I could go on
forever and ever about DevOps
trust me and so feel free to find me the
conference I'd love to meet as many of
you as I can but if I could if if you
could take one thing away from this talk
I think it should be shift left right if
we take if we take our pipelines and
move everything we're doing at the end
and move it a little bit to the left and
continue to force things left it will
allow us to you know take control of the
process from end to end the original
goal of DevOps and and really allow us
to control our own destiny and when
you're interacting with your boss your
boss's boss your colleagues your peers
you should do that and you should choose
to use your DevOps powers for good and
when we do that I think we build a
better future for ourselves a better
futures for our teams together and a
better future for our world
thank you